en donde nos quedamos expresamos la
integral del ine a lo largo de nuestra
superficie en términos de la diferencia
al dt y eso en el dominio del parámetro
t todo eso lo sacamos de ese punto de r
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es un
poco de manipulaciones algebraicas para
aplicar después el teorema de greene que
aunque no nos dará tiempo de hacerlo en
este vídeo pero así veremos después que
es lo mismo que cuando calculamos la
integral de superficie hace ya algunos
vídeos que era justo está esta misma
expresión entonces lo que voy a hacer
primero es es calcular esta integral
esta integral vamos a reagrupar lo de
alguna forma especial por ejemplo vamos
a escribir esto como la integral desde
ave y lo que voy a hacer es agrupar
primero todos los términos que tengan
a la derivada de x respecto de t
entonces por ejemplo aquí tenemos este
término que tiene la derivada de x
respecto de t y también tenemos este
este también lo tenemos pero bueno
simple aquí estoy pensando realmente que
estoy haciendo la distribución de este
producto no estamos pensando que re
multiplica a estos dos suman dos así que
en realidad estaremos tomando este
primer sumando correcto entonces si
tomamos estos dos que marque con
amarillo lo que vamos a tener es
simplemente a p más
r veces zeta la derivada de zeta
respecto de x que multiplica a la
derivada de x respecto de t muy bien
ahora vamos a tomarnos todos los que los
términos que tienen a la derivada de ye
respecto de t que en este caso es este y
este otro término ok que en realidad es
r por esté sumando entonces vamos a
tener vamos a tener factor izando a la
derivada de ye respecto de t aqu
+ ere por la derivada parcial de z
respecto de y que multiplica a la
derivada de y respecto de t y todo esto
hay que multiplicarlo por la diferencial
de t todo esto va x la diferencial de t
y esto se empieza a volver extraño y un
poquito familiar porque justamente es lo
que habíamos obtenido o más o menos de
la misma forma que lo que obtuvimos aquí
en esta integral de hace algunos vídeos
ok entonces ya es bastante parecido pero
justamente eso nos permite que podamos
aplicar este resultado así que déjenme
copiar y pegar esta expresión
pero por ahí vas te nuts
y así no vamos a intentarlo una vez más
creo que con esto bastará
ok entonces
copiar y pegar
vamos a pegarlo aquí
muy bien ahí está
entonces si lo pegamos aquí vamos a
dejarlo esto por aquí muy bien ahí
servirá entonces una vez que ya hemos
hecho esto podemos comparar fíjense esta
expresión con la que tenemos acá arriba
en este caso lo que va a suceder es que
esta parte es más r zx jugará el papel
de m porque después multiplica a la
derivada de x respecto de t y este de
éste resulta de simplemente distribuir
este este dt con éste con éste suma con
esta suma correcto entonces el papel de
la m lo va a jugar p más
rbc es la derivada de zeta respecto de x
y el papel de nuestra n que es la que
multiplica la derivada de ye respecto de
t pues lo jugará este de acá éste será n
correcto entonces ya que tenemos esto
podemos reescribirlo como la integral de
línea de sobre la curva se 1 entonces ya
no estamos en la región del parámetro es
decir estamos como des parametrizado
esta integral porque ahora lo que vamos
a hacer es simplemente escribir esto
utilizando esta expresión que tenemos
aquí abajo vamos a utilizar la íbamos a
escribirlo como la integral de línea
sobre c 1 que se 1 es la frontera de
nuestra región r entonces vamos a
escribirlo como esta integral de línea
que como es una línea cerrada le podemos
poner este si está este circulito de
quien pues será de m que en este caso es
p más ere por la derivada de zeta
respecto de x
por de equis
n por 10 pero n es q mas ere z y de
correcto entonces estas afirmaciones
todas las que hemos hecho son análogas
realmente calcular esta integral es
equivalente a calcular esta otra
integral por esta propiedad por que que
vimos hace en unos vídeos como repaso
entonces lo que es poderoso de haber
llegado a este punto es que ahora
podemos aplicar el teorema de greene a
esta última integral y con esto
podríamos llevarlo esencialmente a una
integral doble sobre la región acotada
por esta trayectoria hace 1 que es la
que cumpla la que rodea a la región r y
cuando empecemos a jugar con esto
veremos que veremos que llegamos a la
misma expresión al mismo resultado que
llegamos en otros vídeos y que es
justamente este entonces ahí le voy a
parar para continuar en el próximo vídeo